I bring you greetings from the 52nd
freest nation on earth as an American it
irritates me that my nation keeps
sinking in the annual rankings published
by Freedom House I'm the son of
immigrants my parents were born in China
during war and revolution went to Taiwan
and then came to the United States which
means all my life I've been acutely
aware just how fragile and inheritance
freedom truly is that's why I spend my
time teaching preaching and practicing
democracy I have no illusions all around
the world now people are doubting
whether democracy can deliver autocrats
and demagogues seem emboldened even
cocky the free world feels leaderless
and yet I remain hopeful I don't mean
optimistic optimism is for spectators
hope implies agency it says I have a
hand in the outcome Democratic hope
requires faith not in a strong man or a
charismatic Savior but in each other and
it forces us to ask how can we become
worthy of such faith I believe we are at
a moment of moral awakening the kind
that comes when old certainties collapse
at the heart of that Awakening is what I
call civic religion and today I want to
talk about what civic religion is how we
practice it and why it matters now more
than ever let me start with the what I
define civic religion as a system of
shared beliefs and collective practices
by which the members of a self-governing
community choose to live like citizens
now when I say citizen here I'm not
referring to papers or passports I'm
talking about a deeper broader ethical
conception of being a contributor to
community a member of the body to speak
of civic
religion as religion is not poetic
license that's because democracy is one
of the most faith fueled human
activities there is democracy works only
when enough of us believe democracy
works it is at once a gamble and a
miracle its legitimacy comes not from
the outer frame of constitutional rules
but from the inner workings of civic
spirit Civic religion like any religion
contains a sacred Creed sacred deeds and
sacred rituals my Creed includes words
like equal protection of the laws and We
the People my roll call of hallowed
deeds includes abolition women's
sufferage the civil rights movement the
Allied landing at Normandy the fall of
the Berlin Wall
and I have a new civic ritual that I'll
tell you about in a moment wherever on
earth you're from you can find or make
your own set of creed deed and ritual
the practice of civic religion is not
about worship of the state or obedience
to a ruling party it is about commitment
to one another and our common ideals and
the sacredness of civic religion is not
about divinity or the supernatural it is
about a group of unlike people speaking
into being our alike nests are group
nests perhaps now you're getting a
little worried that I'm trying to sell
you on a cult relax I'm not I don't need
to sell you as a human you are always in
the market for a cult for some variety
of religious experience we are wired to
seek cosmological explanations to sacral
eyes beliefs that unites us in
transcendent purpose humans make
religion because humans make groups the
only choice we have is whether to
activate that group nests for good if
you are a devout person you know this if
you are not if you no longer go to
prayer services or never did then
perhaps you'll say that yoga is your
religion or Premier League football
or knitting or coding or TED Talks but
whether you believe in a God or in the
absence of God's Civic religion does not
require you to renounce your beliefs it
requires you only to show up as a
citizen and that brings me to my second
topic how we can practice Civic religion
productively let me tell you now about
that new civic ritual it's called Civic
Saturday and it follows the arc of a
faith gathering we sing together we turn
to the strangers next to us to discuss a
common question we hear poetry in
Scripture there's a sermon that ties
those texts to the ethical choices and
controversies of our time but the song
and the scripture and the sermon are not
from church or synagogue or mosque they
are Civic drawn from our shared Civic
ideals and a shared history of claiming
and contesting those ideals afterwards
we form up in circles to organize
rallies register voters join new clubs
make new friends my colleagues and I
started organizing civic Saturday's in
Seattle in 2016 since then they have
spread across the continent sometimes
hundreds attend sometimes dozens happen
in libraries and community centers and
co-working spaces under festive tents
and inside great halls
there's nothing high-tech about this
social technology it speaks to a basic
human yearning for face-to-face
fellowship it draws young and old left
and right poor and rich churched and
unchurched of all races when you come to
a Civic Saturday and are invited to
discuss a question like who are you
responsible for or what are you what are
you willing to risk or to give up for
your community when that happens
something moves you are moved you start
telling your story you start actually
seeing one another you realize that
homelessness gun violence gentrification
terrible traffic mistrust of newcomers
fake news these things aren't someone
else's problem they are the aggregation
of your own habits and omissions society
becomes how you behave
we are never asked to reflect on the
content of our citizenship most of us
are never invited to do more or to be
more and most of us have no idea how
much we crave that invitation we've
since created a civic seminary to start
training people from all over to lead
civic savagery gatherings on their own
in their own towns in the community of
Athens Tennessee a feisty leader named
Whitney Kimball co-leads hers in an art
and framing shop with a youth choir and
lots of little Flags a young activist
named Berto Aguayo led his Civic
Saturday on a street corner in the back
of the yards neighborhood of Chicago
Berto was once involved with gangs
now he's keeping the peace and
organizing political campaigns in
Honolulu Raphael Bergstrom a former pro
baseball player turned photographer and
conservationist leads his under the
banner civics is sexy it is
sometimes I'm asked even by our
seminarians isn't it dangerous to use
religious language won't that just make
our politics even more dogmatic and
self-righteous but this view assumes
that all religion is fanatical
fundamentalism it is not religion is
also moral discernment an embrace of
doubt a commitment to detach from self
and serve others a challenge to repair
the world in this sense politics could
stand to be a little more like religion
not less
thus my final topic today
why Civic religion matters now I want to
offer two reasons one is to counter the
culture of hyper individualism every
message we get from every screen and
surface of a modern marketplace is that
each of us is on our own a free agent
free to manage our own brands free to
live under bridges free to have side
hustles free to die alone without
insurance market liberalism tells us we
are masters beholden to none but then it
then it enslaves us in the awful
isolation of consumerism and status
anxiety millions of us are on to the con
now we're real as we are realizing now
that a free-for-all is not the same as
freedom for all
[Music]
what truly makes us free is being bound
to others in mutual aid and obligation
having to work things out the best we
can in our neighborhoods and towns as if
our fates were entwined because they are
as if we could not secede from one
another because in the end we cannot
binding ourselves this way actually
liberate sus it reveals that we are
equal in dignity it reminds us that
rights come with responsibilities it
reminds us in fact that rights properly
understood are responsibilities the
second reason why civic religion matters
now is that it offers the healthiest
possible story of us and then instead of
we talk about identity politics today as
if it were something new but it's not
all politics is identity politics a
never-ending struggle to define who
truly belongs instead of noxious myths
of blood and soil that mark Samus
forever Outsiders Civic religion offers
everyone a path to belonging based only
on a universal creed of contribution
participation inclusion in civic
religion the us is those who wish to
serve volunteers vote listen learn
empathize argue better circulate power
rather than hoard it the vehm is those
who don't it is possible to judge the
vehm harshly but it isn't necessary for
at anytime one of them can become one of
us simply by choosing to live like a
citizen so let's welcome them in Whitney
and Berto and Raphael are gifted
welcomers each has a distinctive locally
rooted way to make faith in democracy
relatable to others their slang might be
Appalachian or Southside or Hawaiian
their message is the same civic love
civic spirit civic responsibility now
you might think that all the Civic
religion stuff is just for
overzealous second-generation Americans
like me but actually it is for anyone
anywhere who wants to Kindle the bonds
of trust affection and joint action
needed to govern ourselves in freedom
now maybe Civic Saturdays aren't for you
that's okay find your own ways to foster
civic habits of the heart many forms of
beloved civic community are thriving now
in this age of awakening groups like
community organizing Japan which uses
creative performative rituals of
storytelling to promote equality for
women in Iceland civil confirmations
where young people are led by an elder
to learn the history and civic
traditions of their society culminating
in a rite of passage ceremony akin to
church confirmation Ben Franklin circles
in the United States where friends meet
monthly to discuss and reflect upon the
virtues that Franklin codified in his
autobiography like justice and gratitude
and forgiveness I know Civic religion is
not enough to remedy the radical
inequities of our age we need power for
that but power without character is a
cure worse than a disease
I know Civic religion alone can't fix
corrupt institutions but institutional
reforms without new norms will not last
culture is upstream of law spirit is
upstream of policy the soul is upstream
of the state we cannot unpolitical een
only downstream we must get to the
source the source is our values and on
the topic of values my advice is simple
have some
make sure those values are pro-social
put them into practice and do so in the
company of others with a structure of
creed deed and joyful ritual and that
will keep all of you coming back those
of us who believe in democracy and
believe it is still possible we have the
burden of proving it but remember it is
no burden at all to be in a community
where you are seen as fully human where
you have a say in the things that affect
you or you don't need to be connected to
be respected that is called a blessing
and it is available to all who believe
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]